- Hold on a second.
Where are you getting
all of that cake from?
- Oh, you guys want to see
something cool?
I don't know
if you're interested,
but I keep track of
all the cakes in the building.
Today's a big one: 19 cakes.
We can hit 'em all,
but we gotta move fast.
You guys hungry?
[rousing rock music]
First, we'll hit
Ron's 53rd birthday, floor 67.
Congrats!
Come on in.
This is Jake and Matt.
We're here for some cake.
♪ ♪
- Mmm!
- Then Tina's baby shower.
- So who's the father?
Do you know who the father is?
- Then Bill Peterson's
successful
gastric bypass surgery,
floor 11.
- I love your hair.
You look fantastic.
[rousing rock music continues]
♪ ♪
- Oh, my god, this is the best
thing I've ever tasted.
- Just a few more parties,
then we have to fire him.
♪ ♪
- Colin, Michael, Jessica, Erin.
- Jessica, Erin, Colleen--
You're not Colleen, obviously.
You're a man.
♪ ♪
[laughter]
- [smooches]
Happy [bleep] birthday!
Whoo!
- Richard's great.
This company would be better
if more people were like him.
- He's just filling his void
with sugar.
He clearly
has an eating disorder.
- Let's do shots.
♪ ♪
[all groaning]
[both chanting "Richard!"]
[rousing rock music continues]
- I love you, Richard.
- I love this guy.
- [laughs ecstatically]
I know we work
for a big corporation,
but it's not that bad.
The people here are great.
Feels like a family.
And we got health benefits.
- Yeah.
Wait, you get health benefits?
- So where are we
going next?
- Next we're gonna
go to the bathroom,
because I have to
throw up.
[rock music ends abruptly]
[door clicks shut]